my name is Michael Davey I'm a
documentary filmmaker and in 2003 I was
sent to Liberia in West Africa for
National Geographic Explorer and I had
one of the most powerful experiences of
my life
Liberia is a country that was created by
freed American slaves in the mid-1800s
so the people of Liberia have always
felt very close affinity to the United
States civilians were dying by the
thousands in this conflict and Liberian
people felt like America wasn't
responding we've just dropped the car of
the hotel and we're making our way up
the American Embassy just up here we've
heard that there are 17 dead bodies
outside the American Embassy that liking
people who put them there on display as
a kind of appeal to America
we rounded a corner we saw this huge
knot of people maybe 200 people gathered
outside the American Embassy they were
screaming they were shouting they were
hurling rocks at the gates of the the
embassy and people were running down the
street past us covered in blood
screaming and hysterical hands were were
tearing at my shirt and hands going into
my pockets and people shoving and
shouting and screaming in my face they
forced us up the road pushed us into the
pile of bodies I'm actually quite
thin-skinned and I don't like death I
managed to some hold myself together
till I saw one woman in particular
[Music]
I just messed up just leaving and
[Applause]
when National Geographic saw the footage
on television that night they ordered us
to evacuate immediately we said no when
we're not going to leave eventually the
situation became so volatile that we
were evacuated we were told to evacuate
and it was one of the most heartbreaking
moments my career
we were abandoning we were leaving and
we were able to escape and they were not
and it felt like a great betrayal
actually we waited in the neighboring
country of Sierra Leone for 12 days
waited into a situation in Liberia
calmed down and then we flew back in
almost the moment we arrived the
conflict escalated again the rebels
continued to lay siege to the capital
Monrovia and people trapped inside
Monrovia we're in a very dire state
hunger they hadn't been able to get
access to food for weeks at the climax
of this conflict you had two groups of
people civilians in Monrovia and he had
civilians trapped in the rebel-held
territory on the other side of the
miserable River who'd been separated
from their friends relatives who were
trapped inside the capital
eventually when President Charles Taylor
agreed to step down a second agreement
was made that the bridge connecting the
Capitol to the rest of Liberia would be
opened and people would be allowed to
cross from one side to the other I
managed to get myself along with the
other members of my team onto the middle
of the bridge as the bridge was supposed
to open and it was the most
extraordinary day
[Music]
when the bridge was finally open I think
something in me let go something in me
broke open and all of that adrenaline
and anger was released and I just I kind
of just collapsed to be honest I felt so
exhausted and and and relieved that for
once there was a happy ending to one of
these very brutal stories
you